all right our subject for this evening
the cost of salvation what did i say
the cost of salvation before i get into
the message let me ask you to do three
little favors for me they're quite
simple
favor number one if you do not need one
of these things as a bible which it is
not
then please make sure that often i just
take mine
because if i ask you i should follow my
own standards
this one is turned off
i told some people i don't recall in
what country
this is the holy bible
this is not a holy iphone and so if you
don't need this
please put it aside and just open one of
these things but if you're using this
that's fine
favor number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and say lord put your words in
that man's mouth
jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9 then the lord
put forth his hand and touch my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in thy mouth and i really
want god to put his words in my mouth
david said in second samuel 23 verse 2
the spirit of the lord spake by me and
his word was in my tongue
i want god's word
in my mouth and in my tongue so from
time to time as i am speaking
just say to god lord put your words in
that man
i make this request very very seriously
the lord will hear you he will answer
you and your mind will be protected
because if god gives me his words then
whatever enters your head will be a
blessing and favor number three think
isaiah 1 18 come now let us do what
reason together set the lord an example
of this god asking us to reason is found
in jeremiah 12 5. if thou has run
with the foot man you know that verse
and they have weary thee
how then cans thou contend come on with
this god calls upon us think
reason
if you cannot keep up with a man how can
you possibly keep up with a horse and so
we serve a god who believes in reasoning
the bible says in mark 12 28 and one of
the scribes came and having heard them
reasoning together jesus reasoned
and so i ask you as your brother in
christ
let's reason at the invitation of god
and isaiah
that god is a reasonable god
satan is unreasonable
god
is reasonable can you say a man for god
let's buzz and pray
dear god thank you for life
thank you father that we still enjoy
freedom of worship
we thank you for safe travel to this
house of worship
as we bow in your presence their father
if we have offended you forgive us dear
god
you can do that because of calvary
grant to us your spirit
because jesus says he will guide you
into all truth
i humble myself before you dear god and
i ask your father to suppress my carnal
nature that my only purpose will be to
lift your name a lifting of truth
grant me simple language god grant me
humility of spirit but also book
expression
bless every family under this roof
a special blessing on brother morgan
we're grateful for his presence put a
special blessing on his family
nowaday god let the proclamation of this
message bring glory to your name and
blessing to your people i pray from my
heart in jesus name let god's people say
amen and amen what's our subject
the cost of salvation
let us take a look
at how big god is
let's see how big he is
let's go to acts 7 the book of acts
written by whom
well paul is a good name but not paul
luke yes what other book did luke write
luke yes he wrote the book of luke he
wrote two books the gospel of luke of
acts both written by the same man and
look what's with paul on some of paul's
journeys so when you read the book of
acts and you see we did this and we did
that is because luke was present with
paul at the time luke 7 we'll read from
first for
this is stephen giving a powerful sermon
that led to him losing his life
act to seven reading from verse 47.
i'll give you five more sec find it
is there a camera on me
there is all right well i'll stay put
if you found that now say amen
solomon built him a house
how be it the most high god what
dwelleth not in what
temples made with hands as saith the
prophet
heaven is my what throne come on and
earth my what footstool what house will
he build me or what is the place of my
rest now
god says
heaven all of heaven
is my throne
the earth
is a footstool
i'm sure you have footstool there's some
chairs that have a little foot stand you
sit on the chair you put your foot on
that stand god says this earth is
nothing more than a footstool for me
and my throne is all of heaven
go to isaiah chapter 40 4-0
isaiah chapter 40 4-0 we'll read verse
15 we're looking at the bigness of god
it's ten minutes after seven
i'll release you before eight is that
okay
no one answered me so i'll release you
by nine
okay
all right isaiah chapter 40 we'll read
verse 15.
chapter 44 0 verse 15.
behold the nations are what
as a drop of a bucket and are counted as
what the small dust of the balance now
isaiah is trying to express how big god
is or how little we are compared to god
behold the nations are as a drop of a
bucket you've got a bucket it's filled
with water and there's a little hole at
the bottom and a drop
falls off
isaiah says we are no bigger than that
in the eyes of god and are counted as
the dust the small dust of the bucket
behold he lifted up the aisles as a very
small or little thing in other words
isaiah is saying god can lift up an
island
as though it's a golf ball
god is a big god
let us go to daniel chapter 4
daniel chapter 4 let's read verse 35
we're looking at the bigness of god
isaiah
it's daniel sorry thank you very much
for being alert daniel chapter 4 we'll
read verse 35.
do you have daniel
chapter 4
verse 35
and all the inhabitants of the earth are
what reputed as
nothing
all the inhabitants of the earth are
reputed as
nothing compared to god
he goes on to say he doeth according to
his will in the the armies of heaven and
among the inhabitants of the earth and
none can stay his hand or say unto him
what do is thou there is no power in the
universe that can stop god
in heaven or in earth the bible says he
doeth according to his will in the in
armies of heaven and among the
inhabitants of the earth whether on the
earth or in heaven god's power is
supreme
god is a big god
let's go to psalm 115 we'll read verses
1 from verse 1.
psalm 115
reading from verse 1 our subject is what
the cost of
salvation
do you have psalm 115
reading from first one welcome those of
you coming in god bless you
be grateful he brought you safely
not unto us o lord not unto us but unto
thy name give glory for thy mercy and
for thy truth sake
wherefore should the heathen say where
is now their god what's the answer but
our god is where
in the heavens finish that first
he hath done come on whatsoever he have
pleased
you and i can't do that
god does
whatever he wants
this is god
the great god let's go to acts 17 let's
read from verse 22
the book of acts
verse 22 our subject the cost of
salvation
the book of acts
the superstar of the book of acts is the
holy spirit by the way
we see how he led the work after jesus
christ left
acts 17 reading from verse 22 let me
pray again father as i continue to speak
to your people whom you love speak
through me their god help me to deny
self and to seek only to glorify your
name in the name of jesus christ i pray
amen
acts 17 from
then paul stood in the midst of mars
hill and said ye men of athens i
perceive that in all things you're too
superstitious for as i passed by and
beheld your devotions i found an altar
with this inscription to the unknown god
whom therefore ye ignorantly worship him
declare i unto you now paul goes on to
say god that made the world and all
things therein seeing that he is lord of
god
heaven and earth dwelleth not in temples
made with hands neither is what
worshiped with
as though he
needed anything seeing he giveth to all
what life and breath and all things paul
is saying this god whom you don't know
he does not need anything from us
but in verse 28 paul says in him we live
and move and have our being he needs
nothing from us
to survive
because god is life itself but we need
god because without god we cannot live
or move or have our being and so paul
tells those gathered on mars hill this
god whom you do not know whom you
worship ignorantly is the god of heaven
and earth the god in whose eyes people
are like dust the god in whose eyes the
earth is the footstool the god in whose
eyes all of heaven is a throne the god
in whose eyes cannot be uh uh housed in
a man-made structure
this is god
i'll tell you something else about god
go to genesis chapter 1.
genesis 1 we'll read from verse 1 our
subject the cost of salvation
genesis 1
reading from verse 1 and i usually read
almost always from the king james
version of the bible shouldn't take you
long to find genesis 1 verse 1. are you
there in the beginning
god created the heaven and the earth and
the earth was without form and void and
darkness was upon the face of the deep
and the spirit of god moved upon the
face of the waters and god what
said
let there be light
read the next few words
and there was light god is so powerful
he just has to speak
and what he says
comes to pass
your words and mind cannot do that
the words of the angel gabriel cannot do
that
and god said
let there be light
his very word has power to create
verse 6 and god said let there be a
firmament verse 9 and god said let the
waters under the heavens be gathered
together unto one place this god about
whom i am speaking is so powerful that
his word created the universe
that's a big god
by the way
that god is jesus christ
come on say amen for jesus
equal with the father
that's jesus
it was jesus who said
let there be light
you look as though you don't believe me
did you hear what i said
it was jesus christ who said
let there be light
go with me to hebrews chapter one as i
continue the cost of salvation i have a
lot of time so please don't worry
hebrews chapter one let's read from
verse eight now this is god the father
speaking and i need to stress that god
the father is speaking to the son
a remarkable uh passage in all of the
bible hebrews chapter one the entire
chapter is fascinating it upholds the
divinity of jesus christ as verily as
chapter 2 uphold the humanity of jesus
christ verse 8 of hebrews 1.
and thou oh let's read verse 10 and thou
lord in the beginning has laid the
foundation of the earth and those are
the works of thy hands this is god the
father saying son you are the creator
thou lord in the beginning has laid the
foundation of the earth and the heavens
are the works of thy hands
they shall perish
but thou romanist in other words a
created thing it's a way the creator can
never pass away
he's eternal they shall perish but
finished and they all shall wax all at
that the garment and as a vesture shall
thou fall them up and they shall be
changed but thou art the same and thy
years shall not fail the father himself
declares that the son is eternal while
we as human beings we argue about the
eternal nature of jesus the father
declares the son is eternal
and the son is the creator
now having said that
you can argue the father
who identifies christ
as the creator go now to psalm 90
9-0 that psalm was written by moses by
the way
a powerful psalm read it sometime
memorize it
psalm 90 reading from verse one what's
our subject
cost of salvation
is twenty after
seven
lord
thou has been our dwelling place in all
generations
before the mountains were brought forth
or ever thou has formed the earth and
the world even from everlasting to
everlasting thou art god what do you
understand by everlasting to everlasting
let me ask you this
how long is everlasting
it's forever now how long is everlasting
to everlasting
now who is being described as
everlasting to everlasting jesus christ
because he formed the mountains he
formed the earth that's what the father
said in hebrews 1 verse 10 and now moses
refers to the creator as everlasting to
everlasting my brothers and sisters
despite what some adventists believe
jesus christ has always been god
had no beginning
because a god cannot the beginning only
creation has a beginning god cannot have
a beginning we're talking about the
bigness of god
christ who came to die
now having said that
let's go to psalm 8.
psalm 8
well-known psalm
psalm 8.
you have that
nobody answered the preacher
you have it ok
let's read from verse 3.
psalm 8 reading from verse 3.
how many of you have the king james
version may i see your hands oh
something asks you to read for me but
you never do maybe you're shy i don't
know all right
when i consider what
thy heavens the works of thy fingers
when i see what you have made the vast
universe
the moon and the stars
what is man
that thou art mindful of him how does
the bible describe us dust of the earth
in the eyes of god we are reputed as a
drop of a bucket psalmist says what is
man when he looks at the bigness of god
his question is very legitimate what is
man that thou art mindful of him and the
son of man that thou visites him how can
such a big god make time for such an
insignificant puny being such as i
therein lies
one
insight into the love
of god
listen to ellen white
the desire of ages page 48 paragraph six
what did i
say the desire of ages
page 48
paragraph 6. listen carefully
it would have been an almost
infinite humiliation
for the son of god
to take man's nature even when adam
stood in his innocence in eden
let me put that
in bisbee english
when adam was sinless
his level of existence was so low
that if christ had become like him in
his sinless state it would still have
been insulting for christ
even to take the form of sinless
humanity
because humanity is created
how can the creator take a form that's
created and so eloise says it would have
been an almost infinite humiliation for
the son of god to take man's nature even
when adam stood in his innocence in eden
but jesus accepted humanity when the
race had been weakened by 4
000 years of sin
this big god
came down to our level
are you following me
or are you just being nice by nodding
your heads
listen to me again
this god that the universe cannot
hold condescended
to become like one of us
subject to temptation
and subject to death
let's look at death
go to first corinthians 15 read verse 26
we're looking at death
why would god
make arrangement
to experience
death very opposite of all god stands
for the bible frequently refers to god
as the living god the living god the
living god
do you have first corinthians 15
verse
let me pray again father in heaven as i
continue continue to pour your spirit
into me not for my sake their god but
that what i say might be clear and may
draw your people to you in jesus name i
pray amen
first corinthians 15 26 what does that
verse say
the last command enemy
that shall be destroyed is death
because death
goes contrary to everything god intended
when he created heaven and earth
death was not a part of god's plan at
all death is the condemnation of the
broken law of god death
when adam and eve sinned a plan was put
into action the plan had been developed
long before this end the plan had been
developed before they were made
the plan was
that the creator god
the eternal god who himself is life
what did jesus say at the tomb of
lazarus i am
the resurrection come on and the life
what did jesus say in john 14 6 i am the
way
the truth come on and the lord did jesus
say in john 5
40 he will not come to me that he might
have life
what does 1st john 5 say and this is the
record that god has given us eternal
life finish the verse and this life
is in his son
how can this god who is life himself
arrange
to experience death
two things had to happen
the bible says god is immortal
first timothy 6 16 an immortal being
cannot die
life is god god alone has immortality
god had to find a way
to experience death that was the
punishment for sin or the punishment for
violating god's law
death
number two
he had to devise a way
to experience temptation
go to james chapter 1.
it's 7 30 on the dot
james chapter 1.
james is towards the back of the bible
if you work your way up from revelation
you'll probably find it much more
quickly
you have james chapter one
we'll read from verse 13
of james one
when you found it say amen
amen
if you're still looking say amen
all right we have two honest people in
the church
but we don't have all night
james 1 reading from verse 13 let's read
together if you don't mind let no man
say when he's tempted i am tempted of
with god for god cannot be tempted with
evil neither tempteth he any man now the
bible says god cannot be tempted
yet therefore he had to find a way to
experience temptation adam felt it and
he felt it and as we feel it and so the
answer was in order for god to
experience temptation in order for god
to experience death god would have to
become like one of us
and that was a tremendous tremendous
humiliation
and so christ came
born of a woman made under the law
to redeem them that were under the law
the cost
of salvation
that great god that the universe cannot
contain
agreed to come as one of us
after the race had been weakened by 4
000 years of sin
let's look at another cost
of salvation
let us go
to luke
luke 24.
we'll read from verse 36
of luke 24 our subject the cost of
salvation
luke 24 reading from verse 36
luke is gospel number 3
luke wrote mainly for a gentile audience
matthew wrote for jewish audience
luke was a medical doctor
and a historian
an excellent historian do you have luke
reading for verse 36
my king james people read with me and as
they thus speak jesus himself stood in
the midst of them and saith unto them
what peace be unto you come on but they
were terrified and affrighted and
supposed that they had seen a spirit
keep reading and he said unto them why
are you
and why do thoughts arise in your heart
behold my what hands come on and my feet
that it is i myself keep reading handle
me and see for a spirit hath not flesh
and bones as ye see me have pause
when did this occur before the
resurrection or after
after
why did jesus say behold my hands and my
feet
they would see the marks of the
crucifixion
hold that in your mind
and go to philippians 3
you just said they would see the marks
of the crucifixion and you're right
philippians 3 let's read from verse 20.
you have philippians 3
is perhaps the happiest of all the
epistles paul wrote the philippians were
always eager to support paul
so paul wrote a very nice letter to them
he was not angry at all in that letter
as he sounds in first corinthians and in
galatians and other places
philippians 3 from verse 20 let me pray
father as i continue continue to speak
through me i pray please their god in
jesus name amen
my people read with me for our
conversation or citizenship is in heaven
for whence also if we look for whom the
savior the lord
who shall do what change our vile bodies
that it might be fashioned according to
his glorious body stop now when did
jesus get this glorious body
when he rose
and that's the body we'll have when this
mortal does what
puts on immortality
now christ rose with a glorious body
different from the one he had when you
walk the streets of galilee keeping this
in mind now we go back to luke 24.
why are you troubled and why do thoughts
arise in your heart behold my hands and
my feet it is i myself handle me and see
for a spirit hath not flesh and bones as
ye she may have and you correctly said
that christ showed them the marks in his
hands and the marks in his feet
now you put that together with
philippians 3 20 21 what the bible is
teaching us that the resurrected jesus
came from the tomb with a glorious body
that still had the marks of the
crucifixion
now
go to colossians 2.
i hope you don't mind
that i'm taking you from text to text
all right somebody said amen
so i don't feel all alone
colossians 2
verse 9.
keep in mind the book of colossians was
written roughly about 20 years after
jesus went back to heaven
keep this in mind listen to paul what he
writes
read for me what does that say for in
him
dwelleth the fullness of the godhead
what does bodily mean
can that word be used to describe a
spirit
you're taking too long to answer
no
you can't describe a spirit as bodily
because jesus said a spirit hath not
flesh and bones
so when paul says in him it is christ
dwelleth the fullness of the godhead
bodily what is paul saying about christ
20 years after christ has gone back
he's still human
[Music]
take a deep breath
now listen to me again
right now as you sit in human form
christ is in heaven in human form a
glorified body but human
go to first timothy chapter
2. 25-8
first timothy chapter 2.
let's read verse 5.
you have first timothy chapter 2
verse 5
my people what does that say
father is
one god come on and one mediator between
god and men who is that the man christ
jesus not the spirit
the man
this book was also written roughly 20
years after jesus went back the bible
teaches us christ went back to heaven in
what form physical form
now let's see where he went go to
colossians chapter 3
colossians 3 also written by paul
colossians is very similar to if
take some time compare the two epistles
very similar
some passages almost sound word for
words same thing as second peter chapter
two and the book of jude very very
similar isaiah 37 and second kings 19
almost word for word
colossians 3 reading from verse 1.
are you ready
read with me
if he then be risen with christ
seek those things which are above come
on where christ said it where
on the right hand of
keep reading set your affections on
things above not on things of the earth
now we're told christ sits
next to the father above
then you tell me use your imagination
and see god on the throne all you'll see
is light because you can't see him you
can see jesus because his light is
covered in human form now here's all the
light an elo white soil
next to the light
there's a personality sitting
in what form is that personality
human
then tell me something about the godhead
since christ came died and went back
don't after that answer this before
christ came as a human being
in what condition were the three members
of the godhead
three
spirits
three spirits
since christ died and rose what's now
the description of the godhead two
spirits come on
and one man
who is also god
uh you're not listening to me
you're sleeping with your eyes open
there are now two spirits with one man
who's also god what am i saying there is
a human being in the godhead the
composition of the godhead changed
in order to save us
you didn't get what i just said
let me say it again
the composition of the godhead
changed as part of the price of our
salvation now there is god the father
spirit god the holy ghost spirit god the
son man and god
and that man represents you and me
go to ephesians chapter 2 verse 6.
ephesians 2 verse 6 we just said christ
sits on the right hand of the father and
he does
let's go to ephesians two for six and
get some good news and somebody ought to
say amen when you read that if you put
two and two together
you have ephesians two for six
read with me and hath
raise us up together and made us sit
together come on in heavenly places come
on in christ jesus where are the
heavenly places on the right hand of god
because that's where jesus sits and we
sit in heavenly places in christ
therefore in christ we sit right next to
the father
how can you sit there
and still fall in sin over and over
again
because we don't understand
or appreciate
what salvation has made available to us
in jesus christ you and i sit
on the right hand of god let me tell you
something else no angel has that
privilege
not gabriel
gabriel comes into the presence of god
gabriel does not sit on the right hand
of god you and i in christ we sit on the
right hand of god
let me ask you this
if the president of the united states or
some country
sat right next to you would that not
affect your behavior yes or no yes
there's some things you wouldn't do
the things you wouldn't that's the
president of united states that's the
queen of england that's the queen of
sheba i have to behave a certain way
if a young man has a girlfriend
and the mother comes and sits in the
living room there's some things they
will not do are you following me why the
mother is sitting there
now
you and i
in christ where are we sitting on the
right hand of god
there are some things we should not do
if we understand where we seated christ
we're talking about the cost of
salvation
let's look at the wounds of christ again
in his hands
his head
his side his feet all over from top to
bottom
what are the wounds in the head
the crown of thorns in the side
the roman soldier in the hands and feet
the nails from top to bottom christ has
the scars he will carry
forever
now let's imagine
you are visiting from another universe
and you visit this universe
and you're in the new world and you see
jesus walking with
you
and this visitor from another universe
looks at jesus and looks at you
and he noticed jesus has scars you have
none
so he asked a question what did he do
ah you're not listening to me
what did he do
but what will you say immediately
it was me
not i did that
i should have that
but he took it
as part of the cost come on
of salvation
he did nothing wrong and so the thief on
the cross said this man hath done
nothing on this
you think salvation is cheap
when christ was on the cross he cried
out my god come on my god
why hast thou forsaken me it was the
first time
in all eternity the father and the son
had been separated
and otherwise says
there was a sundering you know what a
sundering is
a tearing i thank you very much you take
something and you
the separation of the father from the
son on the cross
cause a sundering in the godhead
and elohim writes the father said
it will never
happen again
because it was traumatic for the father
and the son
let me introduce something else to your
mind at 7 45.
when paul
persecuted the church acts chapter 9
chapter 22 chapter 26 and god knocked
him off the horse and he said
the voice said saul saul what
jesus did not say
why persecute us
the church
he said white persecutors thou
me what does that tell you about christ
and the church
what affects the church come on talk to
me
affects christ when the church hurts
when the church is happy
yes
no
that same relationship between christ
and the church exists between christ and
the father
listen to john 15 verse 9 as the father
hath loved me
so have i loved you so we have the
father and the son with the love the son
and the believer with the love jesus
says as the father hath loved me so have
i loved you in other words the pattern
for christ loving the disciples is the
love the father has for him the same way
christ is affected by what happens to
the church the father was affected by
what happened to jesus
and so while the bible tells us in luke
22 44 his sweat was as it were great
drops of blood falling down to the
ground the father felt it
you know i said the father suffered with
his son
what's your subject for tonight
the cost of now why did they go through
all of that
for you
not the person next to you forget that
person for now
you
remember the parable of the lost sheep
what man of you having 100 sheep if you
lose
one
doth not leave the 1909 in the
wilderness and go after that which is
lost until he find it this is what
christ came to do for he told nicodemus
not nicodemus zacchaeus the son of man
is come to seek and to save the shepherd
when seeking that lost sheep one sheep
now if you are statistician and you lose
one sheep you still have a hundred
statistically
are you following me
statistically 9.7 is 10.
yeah you're not following me
ah time for me to leave
following me
statistically if you're doing statistics
8.9 is 9.
and eight point three is eight
not with god
god is a mathematician
not a statistician
as i like to say if neyman had dipped
6.9 times he would still have been a
leper now a statistician would have
cleansed him
not god
once she went astray observed the
shepherd left in 1909
which means he wanted a one-to-one
when he found that sheep it was just the
sheep and the shepherd i'm telling to
you the plan of salvation was for you
and so you can read john 3 16 for god so
loved
[Music]
for god so loved me and that's
theologically correct
you need to understand as i close the
cause of salvation
all the suffering
the sacrifice and the angel suffered
the holy spirit suffered because hebrews
9 14 tells us christ through the eternal
spirit offered himself without spot to
the father through the spirit father son
holy ghost angel suffered
to save one world
narrow it down to save
one person
and narrow it down to pay the price for
one sin
you know why christ had to come and die
because adam disobeyed god
that's why
i'm not getting through let me try again
if normal sins had been committed after
adam's sin
jesus would still
come
so effectively he died for watson
it also tells us about the horrible
nature of one sin
however small that sin may be or cute
and so tonight
the cost
of salvation
when you consider that cost surely you
can give an offering to the church can
you say amen when you consider the call
surely you can make time to go on some
missionary trip or give up tracks to
somebody surely it becomes easier to
make time for god because god did not
simply make time for you god made life
for you
tonight
there's a human being
in the godhead
because of the plan of salvation
and that human being looks like you not
like gabriel
tonight
there are scars in the godhead that
never existed before listen to me a
perfect godhead has scars
the cost of salvation
now you can understand why the bible
says
how shall we escape
if we neglect come on
so great salvation
i thank god for the cost
of salvation and as i stand in your
presence tonight i recommit my life to
god
to preach
proclaim
thus saith the lord and to let men and
women know wherever i am sent there's a
god who loves to such a degree only a
divine being can measure that love but
we try to understand it in john 3 16 for
god so loved the world that he gave
someone equal with himself for god soul
of the world that he gave the one who
said let there be light
for god so loved the world that he gave
the one who said on lazarus lazarus's
tomb i am the resurrection and the life
for god soul of the world that he gave
the one of whom the bible says for the
lord himself shall descend from heaven
with a shout with the voice of the
archangel and with the trump of god and
the dead in christ shall rise first god
gave the person who is life himself and
that person
is jesus christ
is salvation expensive yes
can we give up sin for a god who
suffered so much for us yes how many
will say father thank you for this
reminder of the cost of salvation i
recommit my life to you freely and
happily can i see your right hand please
i reap ah look at those hands stand up
with me please stand up with me god is
pleased
i know he is
has bowed eyes closed
dear god in heaven we thank you so much
for your love which we cannot measure or
fully understand we accepted by faith
they god the greatest power in the
universe is the power of your love
we thank you father that's seated on
your right hand is a human being who's
also a god
we're sorry the godhead is now scarred
but we thank you for that sacrifice
we thank you to god for condescending in
the person of your son to become like
people whom the bible describes as the
dust of the earth
we thank you that your son suffered
tremendous humiliation
this pat in his face they blindfolded
him punched him and asked him to
prophesy who hit you
they nailed him to a cross
and even on that cross he said forgive
them
because he came to save
father as we stand in your gracious
presence we recommit our lives to their
god and we ask you day by day unfold to
us the depth of your love that we may
sense the great debt we owe you
bless every family
a double blessing on the children
a special blessing on our guests bring
us back tomorrow night dear god to hear
your word again but for now take us home
safely let the angels that escort us
stay in our homes and watch over us as
we sleep in jesus name we pray let god's
people say amen and amen
you